So me and Jayda was reflecting about,
and I asked her,
I said,
what did she think was,
you know,
one of the biggest revelations that she
had had about love?
She said that you cannot make a person
happy.
You can make a person smile.
You can make a person feel good.
You can make a person laugh,
but whether or not a person is happy is
deeply and totally and utterly out of
your control.
We came into this false romantic concept
that somehow when we got married that we
would become one.
And what we realized is that we were two
completely separate people on two
completely separate individual journeys
and that we were choosing to walk our
separate journey these together,
but her happiness was her responsibility
and my happiness was my responsibility.
We decided that we were going to find
our individual internal private,
separate joy.
Then we were going to present ourselves
to the relationship and to each other
already happened.
It's kind of an unrealistic and can be
destructive to place the responsibility
for your happiness on anybody other than
yourself.